retro-gaming collectors a very low
profile if I didn't open this shop for
the past two weeks I don't think there
are so many collectors big and small
[Music]
hi I'm Phillip Lee I'm 50 years old I'm
running a retro game shop here
I'm standing on a retro gaming stuff
from the 80s
most of them are game boys PC engine SNK
Neo Geo System Sega and many others but
before I started this show I was in
video game business that was way back in
the 1990's if I'm not wrong and then I
got very serious into this gaming
business and this way now other actual
stuff that I have right now is actually
most of them are from my own collection
collected through the years
I'm interested in red retro game
collections but in terms of playing wise
I'm not a true gamer I don't know don't
really play a game that well I started
it's because I like that I tell I find
it funny or cute or know just intricate
me so I just one side is it most of them
most of what I have today
that's how I connect that you got at
that time I don't know retro gaming
there's people who already took it mean
stuff
basically my might for my own I like to
play the game boys die our very first
game boy classic the cray-1 and the
commentary is no that's my favorite
games here today to me this is the
easiest game to play for young and oh
and Italy today I think it's out of
order folks still looking around for me
skip
the first one that I ever bought was
with my own pocket money I think at that
car maybe $28 it's a game and watch men
hole
those game a watch we have in a shot now
of course obviously idea for CS but
Allah customers and asking for it
because they by looking at them they
think back about the younger days when
they have it the Kim and wash consoles
of the says I would love money now some
of them from as low as 80 $90 to those
brand-new cereal box a few thousand
dollar retro gaming is something like
collecting antiques and it come the most
expensive system during during that time
I think is the SNK new job tell the
games of course or anyone must cost up
to about $800 see well such as the
salaries is something like a rich men
give machine
the one-piece day's work quite a lot in
a retro gaming market the price wise mr.
Mehta struck us a pushing my dream okay
my dream is to open a retro gaming
museum but it seems like my dream I
cannot fulfill it suitable so the
circumstances like you've got it getting
a place premises
to display all the stuff so
having this thing lying all around you
know my sorry to those
real collectors who are willing to
collocate if casual gamers just for
playing sick music a waste of money by
color all these gems you know but for
those who I do retro gaming when they
say they see something that it's rare
and they'd love to have it here me you
know their envy or maybe jealous
my wife Stephanie for what was it a
waste of money take a lot of space or
chunks here it is she realized that some
items are worth so much
so the retro gaming stuff that I have
now Oh in good working condition the
technology at that time what they use is
different from now those games are put
into EEPROM until today they are still
working there are less moving parts I
think you will last for many years to
come soon as the new gaming starts when
a lot people go back and retrofit
because like we start give the question
or be shadowed answer beats any of the
ps4 game and stuff graphics fantastic
wonderfu real people inside you know
they spend so much time and effort would
create the beautiful things but no
gameplay no replay value spend $80 six
hours complete during my so-called mind
overseas trip I like to visit and giving
shops so I saw retro gaming in Japan so
in Singapore there's none so I was
thinking why not start when Singapore
I'm proud to be the first one of course
but there again how it goes for here no
social
[Music]